a rendition of beethoven launched the
eighth european parliamentary term in
strasbourg where the 751 meps voted in
their new president for the next two and
a half years just before this another
ceremony was held for parliament's
outgoing members
it was the opportunity to reflect back
but the atmosphere wasn't overly
nostalgic
um
was particularly celebrated for his
35-year service to parliament including
a stint as president from 2007 to 2009
to assist the hemi cycles new president
mep's elect 14 new vice presidents
what's their role it's largely a
protocol role replacing the president
when he's not there martin shorts can
also delegate specific duties to them
such as representing the european
parliament at official ceremonies
but the most important function of vice
presidents is as members of the bureau
the european parliament's strategic body
the bureau lays down the rules for the
institutions drafts a preliminary budget
and decides all administrative staff and
organizational matters